you thought you had your fill with
persona with the royal edition last year
well
guess what there's still more persona 5
to be had we have persona 5 strikers
coming out in uh just about a month here
but me and michael hyum got early access
with
the first couple hours of the game and
we're gonna talk about it breaking down
what exactly you do in this game and how
we feel about it so far
michael take it away man all right so
let's start with some of the story setup
like why does persona 5 strikers exist
to begin with
so it's summer time it's july and
joker is back in town so he comes back
and everyone's there to celebrate
everyone wants to hang out so everyone
is like yo let's do all
let's plan this wild summer vacation of
course things don't go as planned and
there's
evil about but it's not exactly the same
sense of evil that you get from the base
game
so there's there's this uh fashion model
pop star her name is alice
and alice alice in wonderland's theme
sort of thing going on here
if you recall persona q it's sort of a
similar thing
so that atlas really likes alice in
wonderland hey
yeah and so what she's doing basically
is using the metaverse to seize people's
desires
to basically turn them into obsessive
fans who end up
going going to see her buying her merch
and building her fame
so she's basically famous and makes a
lot of money because she has turned
everyone into stands
are you okay alice
i i love you alice
please spend your life with me and then
you're like no that's that's not right
we got
we got to fight against that so everyone
bands together and says hey we're going
to go into the metaverse
we're going to figure out what's going
on so that's kind of what they uncovered
so that's an excuse for everyone to get
together
and fight again you know what i'm i'm
here for it
it's it's it's fine uh it's it's not
exactly so one of the things about
persona 5 for me
is how it's able to hammer such
such heavy themes in very thoughtful
ways
and i don't think p5 strikers is exactly
that now again we've only been playing
about the first five hours of the game
so that may change later on but the
initial impressions are
nothing like you would expect when you
play komashita's palace which
is like one of the hardest hitting
intros to an entire game ever
so p5 striker is a little bit lighter in
that regard
one thing about this game is that it
really tries to hammer
home the the tropes of each character
again
maybe a little too much and i know
jean-luc got some thoughts about that
but this is a game that is intended to
usher in players who
either haven't played p5 since 2017
or are completely new to persona 5
because this is on
newer platforms but you know they got a
got to establish that foundation again i
guess
uh and in some ways it's like um well
it's
it's kind of in that regard totally i i
described it as the
direct to vhs uh sequel of persona 5 and
that
it's like it's it's more what you love
but smaller in scope
if you've played other persona spin-offs
you know like i've played all the
persona 4 spinoffs and q and all that
it's kind of similar in that way
it's trying to get you up with the
nostalgia but don't expect
high stakes don't expect character
development uh
it's something that i i didn't like
about like the arena spin-offs is they
kind of flanderized some of the
characters so like
they're like hey man you remember how
chie likes steak well guess what she
can't stop talking about
steak yeah and it's like it's fine it's
fun because you just love those
characters but
it can be a little disappointing maybe
if you were expecting like you know
deep advancement of those characters and
i would say uh going kind of expecting a
similar thing
um you know like yusuke he has to always
make some sort of
allegory to like art we just went
through all the effort to meet up at the
hideout yeah so
let's make the most of it indeed i have
an absolute plethora of discussion
topics for us to mull over
particularly matters such as modern art
and the possibilities within it in our
current age
yeah anything but that you know
ryuji is my boy and um
no i i like him but i feel like
everyone's like hey you're dumb dog
yeah yeah they're just like all right
all right i get it he's not
maybe not the smartest person in the
world but he's got heart so let him have
that
so it's not bad by any means but it's
just like i would say kind of no going
in like you're not expecting like a
like a deep sequel it's more like we're
bringing the band back together to have
a
have a good time uh which is fine i
think if you know that going in you're
gonna
you're gonna enjoy it um but i will say
that i really do
like the new character they introduced
uh sophia
[Music]
yo phantom thieves persona games i think
the the spin-offs usually do a really
good job with their their side
characters and i would say so far
she is no exception i think she is so
basically she is like a computer
program ai that um they meet in the
metaverse and then
uh she ends up on joker's phone she's
like you're you're shopkeeper in the
game then she like buys all your [ __ ]
from like the dark web which i think is
hilarious
yeah it's it's kind of adorable how'd
you find that the dark web
correct futaba it's fine i broke no laws
her shopkeep uh like design excellent
and it's the the music that plays
in in the shop yeah oh very groovy
you want this one do you want to request
that
thanks for your patronage she's she's an
excellent addition
to the cast and i think she has like her
own uh
charm they they maybe lean a little too
into the like i have no memories of
my past trope but that's fine
yeah she's a humanities companion she's
amazed
but there's also another character zen
kichi
who is a cop but there's more to him
and we haven't really discovered what
he's up to quite yet
um of course we'll find out later in the
story and
this game's been out in japan for about
a year at this point
right i have avoided spoilers so i
actually don't know what his
what his deal is if you've seen uh
gameplay of the japanese version
you kind of know how he gets in or that
he gets involved
but we're not quite sure yet and that's
one of the ones i think that's one of
the more exciting things uh past
the sort of first palace the first
chapter uh of this game that we haven't
we haven't really uncovered yet
that's kind of what the game is is like
from a story perspective what are you
actually
doing in this game because it's a muso
game
yeah yeah and so before we get into like
the combat which is an exciting part
of this game it's it it does take on a
bit of the structure of
original persona 5. so you do get to
walk around tokyo you do get to go
around shops but not to the same extent
as you might expect so you might watch
the gameplay like oh i get to walk
around
uh shibuya crossing and i get to go to
shops and and stuff like that
it's like that but bite size you don't
necessarily at least what we've seen so
far you don't necessarily go into a big
bang burger and like
sit down have a meal um level up skill
points or go to the movies
there's also i i guess i should just
mention this right now as a
wild yakuza reference uh when you go
yeah when you go to the the movie
the movie theater with uh makoto you
ever think about how those two games
just switch genres
this year yeah uh you love to see it
but yeah don't ex go going in expecting
that level
level of depth when it comes to the the
exploration of the town but it is nice
that
it the game does incorporate an element
of that and from what we've seen before
at least in pre-release materials you do
get to go around different areas
across japan so excited for that part
when we get to it but for now it's kind
of like okay here's here's a part of the
parts of tokyo that you remember
from the original game now when you go
into the metaverse in the gameplay of
course
you from cn video you might know that
this is a action based game it's
it's a museo games from omega force koei
tecmo known for the dynasty warriors
games and
other franchise spin-offs such as hyrule
warriors
and fire emblem warriors it does take a
lot of
the the kind of design philosophies from
those games
but it also takes in a lot from shin
megami tensei and persona
when you actually play the game so do
not go and go into this game expecting
to button mash your way through it
if you do you're gonna die and you're
gonna die fast because this game can be
very challenging
so you do have an element of you know
using persona spells
and using your environment and as you go
as you crawl through these palaces in
the metaverse you are kind of exploring
them the same way as you do in p5 you
know taking cover
uh doing puzzles across uh the different
areas within the palace
and sneaking up on enemies and ambushing
them but instead of going into
turn-based combat
the you just go into action-based combat
and then you start wailing on them and
casting spells and switching characters
so that's another thing too is that you
can take direct control
of every character now uh with a baton
pass is just a way of framing
how you can switch between the different
characters and another cool thing about
the metaverse exploration is that you
can walk around
as other characters then joking so i'm
playing as i'm playing as makoto and i'm
like yo she's the star phantom thief in
this game now
so she's like darting around the
different cover points and then
ambushing and pulling off the masks of
different shadows around
and that's like it's a small thing but i
it
it kind of provides a little bit of a
different perspective as you do the
exploration so
it's not just about joker anymore and
that's that's important for combat too
because as as you may know uh every
character has
their elemental affinity they have their
different personas that grow in
different ways
and you need to be able to wield them
not just with precision but you need to
make decisions
fast in this game because it's not
turn-based so you can't
you can't plot your every move you can't
really think carefully you've got to be
able to think on the fly
when you pull up your personas to cast a
spell yes it stops time
but there's so much happening as you're
fighting in combat
and you have a lot of enemies because
this is a musso game the there's
huge mobs of enemies and they are also
casting spells so
you need to be hyper aware of what's
going on even though you're wailing on
big mobs and stuff like that because
there are bigger stronger enemies that
are going to
take a lot more to take down and you
need to be thinking about those sorts of
things
as everything else is happening and uh
switching between characters and
realizing
what their strengths are if they need to
be healed
and it's there's just a lot going on
for me the part of the game that i'm i'm
still figuring out how i feel about it
and
and like i think you know i need more
time to really
kind of master it because with persona
you're used to
sort of like this clarity of focus where
because it's turn-based you can take
your time
you can really like plan out precision
attacks and when you're like on point in
that game you're like i know i'm gonna
hit him with this and i'm gonna baton
pass i'm gonna do that and it like it
feels so good
this can feel very messy i'll be like
okay i'm playing as yusuke i know he's
got a combo i should try and hit that
combo but then like
there's a billion other things happen on
screen and oh no you gotta hit this guy
with like a specific weakness spell
before you even know what's happening
it's like oh this character ran out of
sp they can't do anything
this character died it can it can be
extremely overwhelming
i'm not sure how i feel about it yet i
want to give it a lot more time
because i do feel like there's so much
going on that it's like
there's a lot of depth there but it's
just like uh going from persona 5
it can feel very very overwhelming yeah
uh i i
tend to agree with you i think that i'm
hoping that as i spend more time with it
as i go into the next palace and the
next one the next one
is that hopefully we'll be able to get
like a really good
we'll be able to wield that system more
efficiently
once we spend more time with it and kind
of wrap our heads around it
because yeah it's um there's there's a
lot going on because like
when you when you introduce elements of
smt
and persona like those elements are
meant to be
used as like tactically so
you have to you have to think through
those things before you act
so i love how much they've been
translated
into the game but it will
it will take a lot of effort to wield
that properly
because like i said the game is
challenging and some of these enemies
are very tough
but one thing one last thing i'll say
about the combat in the gameplay systems
is that all the characters like their
personalities
and the way that they fight are all
represented and represented extremely
well in this game
like the way haru's axe is feels very
heavy
and you can like charge ryuji's bat
swing with triangle
in mid combo and it just does a ton of
damage and a bunch of area of effect
and like with on like you can charge her
her whip to have a fire effects on it
too for a temporary amount of time
and it's um there's all these small
things that really let these
personalities shine through in combat
and
i really like that uh i think that's uh
that it also makes you want to use
each character because of how fast you
won because of how fast you go through
sp
there are fairly generous checkpoints
throughout the the palace or at least in
the first palace
there's a calendar but you don't manage
days there's no like okay in 10 days i
need to
do the dungeon i need to make this much
progress there's zero pressure in that
regard you can go back to the real
world as many times as you want with
zero consequence
and then refill your sp and then go back
into the metaverse
in between checkpoints you can swap
between characters
in your party which is lets you use
everyone or kind of encourages you to
use everyone kind of like in persona 5.
you do have to think about how you can
utilize everyone
in that regard and it's best that you
get familiar with how they work
because they do have their own specific
quirks in order to use them um
properly in combat and you best learn it
because again
this game can get pretty tough so yeah i
think that for me is is so far
like the biggest draw of this game it's
like you said the the novelty of getting
to play
as all the characters like in combat is
like a lot of fun in the early hours uh
also like compared to other persona
spin-offs like i
i love that it is in 3d i i loved
persona 4 arena story mode but like that
thing's just straight up a visual novel
some fights so like you do get the the
proper presentation of persona 5 carries
over to this game
which i think uh does a lot for it yeah
so i do think that
at least so far persona 5 strikers is
the persona spinoff with the most
production
value like this is the closest a
spin-off has been to the source material
you know you may not get the same sense
of like i live in this city
uh let's go explore and hang out with
everyone but you at least get a little
bit of that
and then when you get into the metaverse
where you know combat has changed very
much
and you're using some of the
sensibilities that you know from persona
but in a whole fresh new way yeah i
i do feel like they they really went for
it uh hopefully it pays off though
because
the thing i mean i don't want to go into
this expecting
uh a heavy story one of the things that
i will always love about persona is that
you know like you said character growth
and
the messages behind that like what are
these characters representing and what
is the game trying to say
through them i'm not expecting that but
you know that is one of the elements
that we do love about persona so
uh you know that may not be there but
we'll see
this is our chance we want to give them
a laugh
and finish them off
[Music]
well we still have a month before the
full game comes out
in north america and you can expect both
me and michael to be talking
a lot more about this game uh in the
coming weeks
so thanks for watching everybody make
sure to like and subscribe if you
enjoyed this video and want to see more
persona content
from michael and me which i hope you do
and catch you later peace
[Music]
you